I assume that you are here to support
your Riverdale co-star who is also in
this movie right yeah absolutely excited
to see the film about Riverdale as when
some of your dental floss and sent it to
the lab your character is not - he seems
to be as a cliffhanger from Wednesday
night's episode what do you have to say
for yourself he's a bit of a creep
longing stare that you do he's he's
really scary but don't judge him yet
give him sometimes there's always more
to the story maybe really part of the
family define family the Cooper's are we
saw last episode you and Betty would let
you're not who you say you are chick
took the DNA test she did she's on it
she's out to find out everything about
me is there more to find out then yeah
of course there's a what do you think
about chick how do you feel I think that
he might actually be a good guy wow
that's good I mean you take somebody in
the situation that he's grown up in and
put yourself in issues and he's in this
perfect family now it's it's a bit of an
adjustment period but he's got he's got
a good heart
he just survivals his number one thing
that's all he cares about any romance
pritchett coming up chick loves anything
and everything he's all about everybody
so there's some things there's some
things in the works he would did you saw
the webcam I was wondering maybe him in
Kevin
would you ship that I would totally ship
that come on you should bet of course
okay great Kevin's wonder yeah it's
great I would love that with the ship
name what is our ship name Kevin oh [ __ ]
Kevin Kevin maybe just coin that I think
we did I love it I'm onboard
I'm the captain of the ship perfect
[Music]